movies take a staggering amount of money
to make and nowadays any budget below
fifty million dollars is considered mid
to low range that level of spending
usually works at the end since movies
also make a staggering amount of money
but not all producers are lucky enough
to earn back their investment in the
case of these films the film's did so
poorly at the box office that they're
considered cautionary tales in
Tinseltown the 13th warrior adapted from
a Michael Crichton novel the 13th
warrior is loosely based upon the myth
of Beowulf while the film earned some
recognition for its expensive set pieces
those costly moments ended up ballooning
the film's budget to one hundred and
sixty million dollars while the box
office returns were only 60 1.7 million
dollars
leaving the film with a deficit of
almost 100 million dollars the movies
failure to find an audience is a bit of
a puzzler since the source material was
by a proven best-selling writer and it
was directed by diehards John McTiernan
but no matter the reason the end results
were so embarrassing that the co-star
Omar Sharif ended up briefly retiring
from acting and discussed The Adventures
of Pluto Nash Eddie Murphy used to be a
reliable hit maker with successes in
everything from action-adventure films
to zany comedies to movies that required
him to suit up for almost every
character he even had some successes on
the family film scene with dr. Doolittle
and Shrek confirming that kiddos like to
laugh at him just as much as adults but
his star power burnt out somewhere
between those films and The Adventures
of Pluto Nash because the film earned
back just 7.1 million dollars of its 100
million dollar budget it's not hard to
see why the film fared so poorly with
mediocre special effects a confusing an
unfunny script and a nonsensical future
setting even Eddie Murphy's big name
couldn't save the film from flopping
hard stealth Rob Cohen was behind the
lens for a number of hits including The
Fast and the Furious and xxx
but his box-office streak took a serious
nosedive when his aviation actioner
stealth crashed and burned at the box
office the film followed a crew of Air
Force pilots trying to control an
artificial intelligence jet but instead
of being a compelling adventure movie it
was more like a science-fiction parody
of Top Gun it grossed just 76 million
dollars against a
135 million dollar budget and made good
on its title by sneaking away from the
theatres largely unnoticed Sahara based
on a massively successful series of
books about a rugged adventurer with a
quick wit and a way with women
Sahara looked like it might be able to
recapture the magic of Indiana Jones
unfortunately for everyone involved the
built-in audience for the books didn't
translate to a box office success and
Sahara grossed a modest 119 point three
million dollars that wasn't enough to
cover its 160 million dollar budget and
81 million dollars in distribution costs
part of it could have just been poor
timing since the movie starred Matthew
McConaughey before his star power
returned in full force with the mechonis
Anse
be a lot cooler if you did but either
way the studio was parched after this
movie's returns Mars Needs Moms Disney's
experiment with motion capture
performance co-produced by legendary
director Robert Zemeckis seemed like a
good idea on paper and Mars Needs Moms
wasn't conceptually off the mark either
as it followed a nine-year-old trying to
save his mom from aliens who wanted to
harness her powers to juice up their
nanny BOTS which is the stuff of a
fairly standard family fare but while
the film's effects were cutting-edge
they gave an almost uncomfortable
eeriness to every characters facial
expressions and rather than an exciting
adventure or a surreal nightmare of a
film the movie ended up being a snooze
audiences on earth didn't have much
interest in it handing over just 39
million dollars in ticket fare against a
whopping 150 million dollar budget the
mouse house might not usually have
trouble wrangling in the kiddos to see
their animated features but this movie
marked a major breakdown for the studio
speaking of Disney flops in outer space
John Carter based on the seminal works
of Edgar Rice Burroughs which influenced
everything from Star Wars to parts of
the DC Universe John Carter seems like a
sure thing on paper in practice though
the film felt ironically derivative and
trite John Carter managed to make
seventy three million dollars
domestically with worldwide sales barely
pushing the film past its 250 million
dollar budget considering it took around
100 million dollars more to market the
movie Disney took a hefty loss on the
would-be tentpole project the title hero
of the film might be less affected by
gravity on Mars but here on earth
was brought down hard our IPD the title
of this film is an acronym for the rest
in peace department a special police
force that takes care of renegade
spirits before they can affect the human
world
it's basically men and black with the
supernatural twist and the casting of
Ryan Reynolds as the upstart partner to
Jeff Bridges grumpy mentor seemed like a
no-brainer unfortunately the movie was
pronounced DOA barely making back 78
million of its 130 million dollar budget
while the failure of certain films can
sometimes be attributed to poor
marketing studio interference or even
rival movie releases that are oddly
similar the blame for RIPD rest pretty
entirely on the film itself it's
relentlessly unfunny bridges and
Reynolds seem like they're so bored with
the script that they might as well be on
the other side but hey maybe they were
just method acting the whole time tough
day
The Lone Ranger the character The Lone
Ranger is a classic part of American pop
culture unfortunately for the makers of
the 2013 reboot of the hit TV and radio
series however the film was plagued with
problems from start to finish for
starters the film drew ire over casting
Johnny Depp as the Native American
sidekick Tonto which prompted massive
criticism over its decision to whitewash
the character then there was the matter
of its bloated budget which was 215
million dollars before marketing costs
and to top it all off critics laughed at
the film for all the wrong reasons
justice is what I seek
something maybe just pick a different
hat next time thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]